Irène Chagot propose voyage sans
passeport il y a quelques jours sa
majesté a séaer empereur d'Éthiopie
rendait une visite amicale à la France
aujourd'hui nous allons faire un voyage
en Éthiopie où le chemin de fer Franco
éthiopien traverse d'abord pendant des
heures les terres désertiques et
inhospitalières puis il grimpe lentement
pour arriver à addisabeba qui se trouve
elle à 2500 m la ville d'adisabeba est
une des plus hautes capitales du monde
avec la pase que nous avons vu ensemble
récemment en Bolivie et la ville sainte
du Tibet
lassa en sortant de la gare vous l'avez
vu toute la ville s'étale devant nous
addisabeba est aussi étendu que Paris
mais en guise de bois de Boulogne il y a
des forêts d'eucalyptus au milieu de la
ville l'élu de Dieu
l'empereur devant l'empereur sont rangés
les depterrasses ce sont à la fois les
danseurs et les chanteurs de l'église et
en même temps ils connaissent les
secrets de la magie et de l'astrologie
et fabrique des
amulettes ils tiennent d'une main leur
bâton de prière ou reposoir sur lequel
il s'appuie parfois pour se
délacer et de l'autre main un
cistre
le maniment du cistre pendant leur danse
est semblable à celui des prêtres de
l'antique Égypte qui figurent sur les
bas reliefs de l'époque pharaonique leur
voix sont rythmés par le teintement de
ses cistres et par des coups de tambour
frappés avec la paumme de la main
les chants des depter sont des
psalmodies vieilles de 15 siècles
savantes et graves très étrangères à des
oreilles
européens
વવા સ
યતાોવા
નાખો
એકનાખ સરવન કરરા
વાર
આજયા
selon les uns c'est ainsi que David
dansait devant l'arche selon les autres
elle est une réminiscence païenne
héritée de l'antique
Égypte
અનાર
્ય
વવાયથ
પજ
તાગોસવા
જય હો
નાખ ો
એકનાખ સર્વ સરાવકોો
સવાર
આજરયા
આવ
les laquets du palais apportent sur des
plateaux d'argent des bouquets de fleurs
des
champs la Bouna en prendra un qui
l'offrira à
l'empereur et les plateaux circulent
dans l'assistance où chacun reçoit son
bouquet la distribution des fleurs
donnant à chacun son
printemps ceci est l'aspect païen d'une
cérémonie par ailleurs essentiellement
chrétienne comme la teste cette croix
d'or richement
CIS addisabeba est en
liè la ville fête les 25 ans de règne de
son empereur nous sommes au théâtre
d'Adis Abeba construit par des Français
et inauguré pour la circonstance on y
joue une pièce en trois actes en H du
Premier ministre l'empereur a décidé que
deux actes serai suff le trème a été
supprimé
vêtu du costume traditionnel un vieux
guerrier pris pour son empereur devant
la porte de l'église Saint-Georges il
tient d'une main son bouclier
d'hippopotame CTI d'or et de pierrerie
et de l'autre sal lance sur sa tête vous
avez pu voir une coiffure en poil de
singe ené de Pierr précieuses et de
pendantif en
or sur le parvis de est de garde de
corps en grande tenue à temp de
l'empereur qui va recevoir dans un
instant la Bouna vêtue d'une chape
blanche le cortège se forme et s'avance
lentement vers l'église Saint-Georges en
tête la Bouna puis l'empereur la
poitrine barrée du ruban de l'ordre de
Salomon en uniforme de maréchal et
coiffé du bicorn à
plume l'impératrice suivie de ses dames
d'honneur
ensuite le prince héritier et sa femme
le ministre de la Défense nationale le
Premier
ministre tout le monde se dirige vers
l'église où le service va se prolonger
pendant 2
he en même temps il se passe beaucoup de
choses sur le Parville l'arrivée du
carrosse fabriqué vous vous le rappelez
spécialement en Belgique pour cette
occasion et qui prendra les souvrin à
leur sortie et la danse des prêves
accompagné de leur
tambours
સમલ
ોવા
જ
après la sortie du clerger tout en noir
à l'issue de la cérémonie religieuse des
rafraîchissement vont être servis sous
une
tente l'empereur la quit suivi de
serviteur qui pent les parasols tel
Salom
et les cavaliers gala vont défiler
devant leur empereur certains portent
des coiffures en poil de lion regardez
bien
après avoir traversé ainsi toute la
ville nous franchissons les grilles du
palaise impérial le peuple tout entier a
acclamé son souverain qui en 25 ans de
règne l'a mené de la barbarie au temps
moderne
vous a proposé sans passeport cette
émission a été réalisée avec un film de
Maurice Clet et le concours de Solange
péter montage Michel l touche script
Nathalie muret son Annique ved
illustration sonore Bernard
gandrti